we're here in tijuana in the busiest
land border crossing in the western
hemisphere in san ysidro you see the
united states behind us and the
officials there and then you can see
to my left there's a small camp here of
russians and these are people that have
fled their country because they oppose
the war with ukraine they've been
telling us
a few stories there's a family
who had to flee after the father joined
an anti-war protest and got arrested and
was told that he could go to prison for
years and so they immediately picked up
two suitcases and fled here other people
that said i've got relatives in ukraine
i can't fight against them i can't be
against them so they felt they had to
flee their country as well and they've
headed here they've been told by these
officials to wait at the moment
obviously these russian uh
people that have had to leave aren't the
priority what we have seen is a
ukrainian mother and her son that have
also come here they showed their
passports and they were immediately let
through into the united states that
wasn't automatically happening for
ukrainians before so there's obviously
been some sort of order at least here to
let ukrainians through now why
are the russians around us fleeing here
rather than someone else they say that
basically europe is close to them at the
moment there's no flights this is one of
the only places mexico that they can go
to with no visa and then they just want
to go from mexico and try and get across
there into the united states and that's
possibly why we're seeing numbers of
russians here and some ukrainians all
trying to get to safety